hey youtubers is charlie big news the
producers are talking about house avatar
is going to be different from the other
evil speedsters on the show we learned
about a new rogue that's coming top and
some rogue war stuff that'll be
happening between mirror master top and
Captain Cold so this is gonna be
breakdown all that stuff so all kinds of
awesome stuff happening they're talking
about flashpoints avatar at the
reverse-flash you barth on the
reverse-flash as well as the new rogue
that they just announced top who will be
like Bonnie they they cashed Ashley
Rickards from MTV's awkward series to be
top she'll be a female version of the
character and she'll be Bonnie to mirror
masters collide I know everybody is so
excited about mirror master they've
already cast him for the show they
announced him a while ago maybe you
missed it because it was during the
summer but just wait a sec it gets even
cooler so they said that the two of them
will have a feud with Captain Cold on
the series now they're all flash rogues
but no honor amongst thieves you know
one of the hallmarks of the flash rugs
is that they never get along like even
if they have a loose alliance everyone
has their own agenda but mirror master
and top will kind of be like a pair
they'll be like the firestorm killer
frost of last season like a Bonnie and
Clyde recurring duo during season three
and yes captain Cole is coming back I
know he died during legends of tomorrow
season 1 but flashpoint so he's still
alive and he's going to be part of the
Legion of Doom on legend season 2 but
you guys want to know all about the
black flash avatar of the season so
that's the important stuff the way
they've been talking like the producers
were talking about Savitt are how he's
different from zoom in the reverse flash
the other speedster villains the show's
done before so one on a practical level
his suit looks different I actually
think it looks cooler than zoom suit to
his powers will be different if you
haven't read him in the comics Savitt
are can create special force fields he
has the ability to transfer kinetic
energy some of the things that the show
has done before so they might change it
just a little bit so that it looks new
but he just he has abilities that the
flash does not know how to counter yet
so expect Barry to get his ass whooped a
couple times before he starts to figure
stuff out so to that effect like one of
the things that I really like about the
flash is that his powers are really
nebula like they're very energy based
but they don't define exactly how those
work
so they just give themselves the number
of different directions to go like as
comics slowly have evolved over the
years the way people use their powers
grows more sophisticated so mirror
master for example when he debuted as
Sam Scudder he really only traveled
through mirrors later versions of the
character like Evan McCullough
discovered the mirror world the world
between mirrors so you go from someone
with a really cool trick just traveling
through mirrors like oh my god that's
really awesome to like this whole other
world inside the mirror like alice's
adventures through the looking glass so
the TV show is starting with the Sam
Scudder mirror master giving it
somewhere to go so that later if they
want to they can do mirror world so I
mean just explain what that means that
means that mirror master on the show
they've just teased him as a villain who
can travel through reflective surfaces
so I'm not expecting them to get heavy
into mirror world right away they're
just giving themselves somewhere to go
in a future season Ashley Rickards like
even if you don't watch MTV's awkward
series she's pretty amazing in the funny
thing about this is that she's actually
a real life member of mensa the actress
herself has like this genius level IQ so
it's just funny how like in the context
of the flash TV show you have this coven
of female geniuses at STAR Labs but in
real life a lot of the women that they
are casting are also geniuses like
danielle Panabaker the person who plays
caitlin snow killer frost she is also a
member of Mensa in real life so if you
wanted to get funny about it you could
say that the flash TV show is literally
one of the smartest TV shows on the air
right now but black flash what the hell
is he going to be doing to bury that's
different than what zoomed it because
Savitt are in the comics was all about
taking speed and they kind of did that
in season 2 so the way they explains
avatars real in like the thing that he's
going to be terrorizing Barry and team
flash with is psychological torture so
the idea behind flash point is that
Barry has to come to terms with the idea
of letting his mother died so that he
can fix all the terrible things that
have happened so it just weighs on him
you can imagine the reverse-flash ebar
thon and Savitt are both torturing Barry
with that idea
all of these problems that have happened
are your fault now you're the villain so
they kind of used you Barth on is a good
example of someone who uses a lot of
psychological torture because he can't
kill Barry because that means that he'll
never become the reverse-flash so he has
to live with Barry but that doesn't mean
that he has to be nice about it it'd be
like if your roommate that you were
stuck with all year was somebody that
you hated but you couldn't do anything
about it so you just terrorized each
other all year long and it just becomes
a living hell so that's kind of like the
flash season 3 Savitt r is going to be
psychologically hazing Barry all year
long everybody's had that one roommate
that they can't stand there's just super
passive-aggressive like you want to kill
them but you can't so you just have to
find a way to overcome that so that's
going to be like Barry versus Savitt are
this season much more psychological
torture with a lot of different types of
Speed Force power so it's going to be a
lot of fun but don't be surprised if
Barry learns or has to learn how to
create an energy shield using the Speed
Force but like last year it was throwing
lightning Zeus style there will be like
new things that Barry learns how to do
with the Speed Force that look really
cool on screen I'm hoping because mirror
master is debuting in their 50th episode
that is a way to do something really fun
and a deep cut from the comics when he
does debut Barry learns how to do the
finger snap sonic boom because if mirror
master can travel through reflective
surfaces then the easiest way to fight
him is to destroy all the reflective
surfaces in the easiest way to do that
is to just do the finger snap so that
you smash all the glass all around so
let me know in the comments which new
powers do you think that we're going to
cease avatar used the black flash and
what kind of rogue war do you want to
see between mere master top and Captain
Cold it's going to be so much fun and
for those of you that are asking about
Gorilla Grodd we're totally going to go
back to gorilla City but they did say
that if they were gonna do a gorilla
City episode you would have to be like a
multiple like a two-part episode thing
because it'd be so expensive they
probably have to introduce so levar so
they've probably already started working
on that idea if they haven't already
started writing it we might see it in
the back half no idea when he'll come
back but yes there will be
plenty more gorilla grodd gorilla City
stuff I'll talk more about top and
mirror master in a future video with the
first time top debuted in the comics was
actually a kid flash story so it's a bit
of a hat tip that doing a lot of deep
cuts from the Silver Age kid flash
comics as well as the modern age so if
you're wondering about stories and
characters they're doing you want to
theorize anything from any of those in
any era of the comics is totally fair
game but congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Oliver Queen you can use
the twenty dollar amazon gift card to
buy back part of your company be sure to
private message be on the back end of my
channel so i can get your contact
details so what's going to happen next
is is supposedly information is out that
zendaya is playing Mary Jane Watson and
spider-man homecoming and there's a new
poster for the movie so i'll be doing
that next it's really big if it's true
so that will post later tonight be sure
to subscribe to get that there is a new
round of the giveaway to all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video so a whole bunch
of awesome stuff happening I'm so
excited about the flash season 3 you
guys have no idea there'll be a new
trailer pretty soon to maybe in like the
next couple weeks so just be prepared
for a bunch of new footage to drop very
soon way you guys wait for Mary Jane to
post you can click here for my breakdown
of the spider-man homecoming comic con
trailer and you can click here to learn
all about the flash movie thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight